de lo que quiero hablar en este vídeo es
de las nociones de electro negatividad
lex
pero
cat
tu vida
y una idea muy relacionada sería
afinidad electrónica
sí
mitad
leex
pero nica
y están tan estrechamente relacionadas
que en general si algo tiene una electro
negatividad alta tendrá una alta
afinidad electrónica pero qué es lo que
eso significa la afinidad electrónica se
refiere a cuánto ese átomo atrae
electrones que tanto le gustan los
electrones quizá quiere necesita más
electrones la electro negatividad es un
poco más específica cuando ese átomo es
parte de un enlace covalente cuando está
compartiendo electrones con otros átomos
que tanto quiere abrazar a esos
electrones en el enlace covalente y a
qué me refiero con abrazar electrones
déjame escribir eso
qué
santo
quiere
abrazar
y está claramente es una definición
informal abrazar a los lakes
pero mis
quedarse con los electrones pasar la
mayor parte del tiempo junto a ellos que
con la otra parte del enlace covalente y
esto es cuánto les gusta atraer a los
electrones cuánta afinidad tienen a los
electrones por lo que
qué
tanto
quieren
lake
pero mis
y puedes ver que estas son muy estas son
nociones muy relacionadas esto es en el
contexto de un enlace covalente cuánta
electro negatividad hay ahí mientras
esta la puedes pensar como una noción un
poco amplia pero estas dos tendencias
van sumamente de la mano para solo
pensar en la electro negatividad hacerla
un poco más tangible
pensamos en uno de los enlaces
covalentes más famosos y eso es lo que
ves en una molécula de agua el agua como
probablemente sepas es h2o tienes un
átomo de oxígeno y tienes dos hidrógenos
cada uno de los hidrógenos tiene un
electrón de valencia y el oxígeno tiene
lo podemos ver aquí en su último orbital
tiene 12
456 electrones de valencia 12
456 electrones de valencia y entonces
puedes imaginar que el hidrógeno estaría
feliz si pudiera en cierto modo
pretender que tiene otro electrón
entonces tendría una configuración
electrónica estable el primer orbital
solo requiere 2 electrones el resto
necesita 8 el hidrógeno diría que soy
estable como el helio
si puedo obtener otro electrón y el
oxígeno diría que soy estable como el
neón si pudiera tener 2 electrones más y
lo que pasa es que comparten los
electrones los unos con los otros
este electrón puede compartirse en
conjunción con este electrón de este
hidrógeno por lo que ese hidrógeno se
podría sentir como usando a los dos y se
vuelve más estable estabiliza el último
orbital o estabiliza el hidrógeno y de
la misma manera es electrón podría
compartirse con el hidrógeno
y el hidrógeno podría sentirse más como
helio y luego este oxígeno podría
sentirse como quid pro quo que es la
expresión en latín que significa que
está obteniendo algo a cambio de otra
cosa obtiene un electrón está
compartiendo un electrón con cada uno de
estos hidrógenos y entonces puede sentir
que lo estabiliza parecido a un neón
pero cuando tienes estos enlaces
covalentes solo en el caso en el que son
igualmente electro negativos tendrías un
caso donde incluso ahí no importaría lo
que sucede en el resto de la molécula
pero cuando tienes algo como esto dónde
tienes oxígeno e hidrógeno no tiene la
misma electro negatividad al oxígeno le
gusta más abrazar electrones que al
hidrógeno y entonces estos electrones no
permanecerán una cantidad igual de
tiempo ya sabes aquí solo dibuje estos
electrones de valencia y estos puntos
pero como sabemos los electrones están
en este tipo de mancha alrededor
del núcleo
alrededor de los átomos y entonces en
este tipo de enlace covalente
los electrones los dos electrones que
representan este enlace pasarán más
tiempo alrededor del oxígeno del que
pasarán alrededor del hidrógeno y estos
dos electrones pasarán más tiempo
alrededor del oxígeno del que pasarían
alrededor del hidrógeno y sabemos eso
porque el oxígeno es más electro
negativo y hablaremos de esa tendencia
en un segundo esta es una idea muy
importante en química y especialmente
después cuando estudias química orgánica
porque ya sabemos que el oxígeno es más
electro negativo los electrones pasaron
más tiempo alrededor del oxígeno que del
hidrógeno crea una carga parcial
negativa en este lado y cargas parciales
positivas
en estas secciones lo que hace que el
agua tenga muchas de las propiedades que
tiene y veremos mucho más de eso en
otros vídeos y también cuando estudias
química orgánica muchas de las
reacciones similares que pasarán pueden
ser pre decididas muchas de las
moléculas parecidas que se forman pueden
predecirse basándonos en la electro
negatividad especialmente cuando
empiezas a ver números de oxidación y
ese tipo de cosas la electro negatividad
te dirá mucho ahora que sabemos que es
la electro negatividad pensemos un poco
en que es mientras vamos a través de un
periodo
digamos que empezamos en el grupo 1
y vamos al grupo mientras vamos por todo
el camino digamos hasta los halógenos
por todo el camino hasta la columna
amarilla de aquí cual pensarías que
sería la tendencia para la electro
negatividad y nuevamente una manera de
pensar en eso es pensar en los extremos
piensa en el sodio y piensa en el cloro
y te invito a pausar el vídeo y pensar
en eso asumiendo que ya lo intentaste de
alguna manera es la misma idea o es una
idea similar a energía de ionización un
elemento como el sodio sólo tiene un
electrón en su último orbital
será difícil completar ese orbital y
entonces para llegar a la estabilidad
será más sencillo ceder el electrón que
tiene para que llegue a una
configuración estable como el neón este
realmente quiere ceder un electrón y
vimos en el vídeo de energía de
ionización que por eso esta tiene un
nivel bajo de energía de ionización
toma demasiada energía en un estado
gaseoso remover un electrón del sodio
pero en el cloro es lo opuesto está solo
un electrón de completar el orbital lo
último que quiere hacer es ceder un
electrón que quiere demasiado obtener un
electrón para obtener una configuración
de argón para que pueda completar su
tercer orbital lo lógico aquí es que al
sodio no le importaría acceder un
electrón mientras que el cloro en serio
amaría recibir un electrón por lo que es
más probable que el cloro abras
electrones mientras que es muy poco
probable que el sodio abras electrones
por lo que esta tendencia de aquí cuando
vas de izquierda a derecha tu electro
negatividad déjame escribir eso te
volverías más electro negativo más el
electrón
electro que a ti no
mientras vas a la derecha como piensas
que sería la tendencia si vas hacia
abajo mientras bajas en un grupo cómo
crees que sería la tendencia mientras
bajas bueno te daré una pista piensa en
piensa en radios atómicos y dado eso
pausa el vídeo y piensa en cómo sería la
tendencia obtendríamos más o
obtendríamos menos electro negatividad
al movernos hacia abajo nuevamente estoy
asumiendo que ya lo intentaste y como
sabemos del vídeo de radio atómico
nuestro átomo se hace más y más grande
mientras tenemos más orbitales y
entonces el cesio tiene un electrón en
su último orbital en su sexto orbital
mientras que digamos que el litio tiene
un electrón todo lo de aquí todo
elemento del grupo uno tiene un electrón
en su último orbital pero este electrón
55 a ese electrón en el último orbital
del cesio está mucho más alejado que el
electrón más alejado en el litio o en el
hidrógeno y debido a eso hay más
interferencia entre ese electrón y el
núcleo debido a todos los electrones
entre ellos y también está más lejos por
lo que es más sencillo solo tomarlo por
lo que el cesio es muy probable que se
da es muy probable que se da electrones
es mucho más probable que el de
electrones que el hidrógeno mientras vas
hacia abajo de un determinado grupo t
2 - y lake
pero no
electro negativo basándonos en esto
cuáles serán los átomos más electro
negativos serán los que están hasta
arriba y a la derecha de la tabla
periódica serían estos de aquí estos
serían los más electro negativos algunas
veces no pensamos tanto en los gases
nobles porque realmente no son así de
reactivos ni siquiera forman enlaces
covalentes porque simplemente son
felices mientras que estos personajes de
arriba algunas veces formarán enlaces
covalentes y cuando lo hacen realmente
quieren abrazar a esos electrones y
cuáles son los menos electro negativos
algunas veces llamados electro positivos
estos elementos de aquí abajo en la
izquierda estos de aquí solo tienen ya
sabes en el caso del cesio tienen un
electrón para acceder lo que los llevará
a un estado estable como el xenón o en
el caso de este grupo 2 sólo tendría que
ceder dos electrones
pero es más fácil ceder tos que ganar
todo un grupo de ellos y son átomos
grandes y entonces esos electrones son
menos atraídos al núcleo positivo por lo
que la tendencia en la tabla periódica
es que cuando vas desde abajo en la
izquierda hasta arriba en la derecha
obtienes más
más electro electro me da
si me da